okay hey I guess it's your boys psycho
sample and we're playing again called
perineum and you don't know a premium as
it's the muscle anatomically it's a
muscle around the strength it feels it's
shot so we're going to start the scan
him going wrong first we didn't know
what they didn't understand that they'd
look in her eyes hmm that unnatural
wouldn't lurch emotionless she moved
about that it just sounds stupid
carloads redesigns most of the crew
minutes power already terrible price
much like my hat was either last I could
hear their footsteps on the smell out of
my cabinet little steps moving as one
not safe okay so something is trying to
gather this guy's perineum and I don't
know what it is but I'm about to find
out oh they are sighs its premium ours
right strobing from getting cold
oh yeah Nicole yeah brain gone better
dr. Turner open up turn up turn out my
eyes swimming swimming why are they
going swimming come on - there's not
really so worried about pumps had to
name it Jim guy is a gem has a chance
living in his body now i clenched my
teeth against another wave of agony oh
yeah keep it together Jim Bell dings
first it's got to get these bleeding
under control yeah got a broadcast okay
total box anything in there a [ __ ]
now not our Jessica directions I use on
papers funghi was bring the culmination
a bit of pocket okay so it's the fungi I
think barrel nothing to that brow but
let's just see if we can I don't give
you useful and look at these cupboards
small blooms watch there's nothing
there's no okay
what's wrong - mrs. Burke now time to
mass right that we're in Italy hello
sire Wilkins alien that I would you go
for me kneeling down over the body
I noticed the tell-tale inhuman signs on
his face he was also wearing one of
those armbands I've noticed on the
others
god the stains coming off him but as
that was losing consciousness again with
disparate opposite nevertheless a
process that thawing the Kiwis jeans
pocket okay
area looking at the radio my heart sinks
straight [ __ ] language ending up
there
can't reach yes Tappan look he is he is
that area the lock clicks over my eyes
with hungrily past morphine so I'm going
to bring story lobe samples in here
again example called my eyes dance
Carlin membrane stretch original hole
settings from boulders our only way to
go out of cruising spores eyes nostrils
he's so angry I cough and the action
triggers a dagger of pain from my wound
still my man is not to blackout at least
don't black out and you never on a black
out okay iron band blowtorch plant had a
lot of stuff here scourge IRA gun okay
that I that morphine would only slow in
my mind so clenching my teeth to
suppress screams of agony I just did
some penicillin around the world before
bandaging it up okay so he's good that I
guess I I'm done with it
yeah you're done with that brow look and
okay what can we do here screwdriver and
then I'm here to helping us at my shop
okay can't reach
hang on I know don't cut it with my BAE
there's no going to work I can't voice -
that's not gonna help they don't lose
you won't work how either right click
don't want to waste you take assets that
we would now get out of that cut it okay
okay God got it Jonesy
yes stupid lady okay um let me see what
else is around here I don't really
explore the right side thing at all
there's nothing go what's up there
nothing it's not important
in LA Kenny was stuck fast now that's
how that way for the door with the
screwdriver it's too small to be of any
use
don't want to wait brap yeah in our way
senator Nia no you saw nothing human
come on open the door on that way Jim
don't do it Jim
don't do it he is lying Harris's line
other [ __ ] door hadn't stand
listening to that thing out there
cracker
so radio working in how's that sound
some mean their way go their way gap
sniffing away the fused wiring I have a
vision collecting beautiful stain
samples with my wife the laughter oh
okay radios he's using I've already
removed the depth and time yes
she's already don't want to what hmm
thank you work together they do carry is
tad jumpy reaching up to cut the wire I
feel something brush against my mind but
is that vast and terrible
that means fleeting whisper of Conte
thinking freight train roaring through
my consciousness I now look a bay I was
drowning now from deep beneath my mind I
just feel that force animating my limbs
like a monstrous puppeteer who knows
something's taking over his perineum is
breaking great a surface oh dear
you know you got to get out of our brow
[Music]
God was that what the others had felt
eyebrow language get help there sleep
okay how can I deal with wet that's down
let's see should be working now out I'm
ready to receive up this is dr. James to
a doctor damn sation fetus 6 6 1 do you
copy
the welcome sound of a friendly voice
comes through the static oh thank god I
need evac ASAP this me something
horrible has happened
well that has that letter Jamestown will
accrue do not land until they see repeat
to not land until they see dr. Parker
here's a pro copy over and out
thank God for that sounds good hello
Matt wavering on my feet
exhausted I sink to the floor to wait
sleep falls like a lead curtain that can
right here down well
you thinking let the furnace today
Snapple like something very wrong to
cold my mind my body stiff and numb the
pain like hot blade being poured over my
hands my feet my face I can't either
toggle to move my legs tearing stuff
away from the pores and floor pray you
gotta get this furnace gone again is you
which is a tricky thing to give me
poison tingling quickly
I can't flame from the blows which is
implying if you calculate a good call
that a car why not go Mirabal cold
ok brow get all stuck
is nothing periodic decayed work thrown
in fan act
stand close
so feel my face I lose some fingers but
I'm alive for now
at what now you bet it is MSS sir it's
quite up Georgie go
his shouts and body-slamming to the
other side
I follow myself for the door but too
late they were like arms does SCAF thang
oh god it's on you how long I can hold
it
I stabbed it slightly I'll or at one of
the arms crap severs the arms with stab
it blowtorch was dropping again it was
screams round so take the knife back
okay here's a knife on this fall you
feel muffled screams from behind finally
I'll feel the door slam closed on it
warm the same
that's disgusting anyways for walks
it's loaded
whipping shaking him up coming out Jim
put it down
look M King huh yeah me I'm coming in no
expansion al kursi
I just got in on me get out of here Rock
get any stupid bag gum damn right Thank
You Cathy babe they told me what look it
wasn't your fault anyway
you know just Paula dead like just
palette just Paulette Jim Turner
then get him
we have Lantana get him get him
papa papa just pop it yeah good good
rhenium very sad very sad how can I hope
y'all enjoy it as a nightmare thank ya